Transcription: Claire Azam
Relecteur: Martini Tosca
(Applaudissements)
J'adore cette histoire,
j'adore cette image,
j'adore cette idée.
La boîte à soleil.
Et là, à l'idée de vous la raconter,
j'éprouve les mêmes sensations que celles
que je ressentais quand j'étais enfant
et que ma maman me racontait
cette histoire.
C'est l'histoire d'une petite fille
qui veut offrir un cadeau
à son grand frère pour son anniversaire.
Et elle a cette idée magnifique.
Elle décide de lui offrir du soleil.
Alors elle prend une boîte,
vous savez, une boîte à coulisse.
Et toute la journée,
elle gambade dans le jardin avec sa boîte
pour tenter de capturer
le moindre bout de soleil.
La petite fille est hyper concentrée
sur sa capture du soleil.
Elle est très attentive.
Elle ouvre la boîte, vite elle la referme.
Et encore, et encore.
Alors son frère est intrigué,
surtout qu'elle cache la boîte
derrière son dos.
« Mais qu'est-ce que tu as donc
dans cette boîte ? »
Et la petite fille, malicieuse,
lui répond :
« Aha ! Avec ce que j'ai dans cette boîte,
tu peux créer et transformer
des milliers de choses.
Mais il faut que tu attendes ce soir. »
Le soir arrive.
La petite fille attrape sa boîte.
Et là, vous savez quoi ?
La boîte brille !
De la lumière jaillit
de tous les interstices !
Alors elle se précipite
dans la chambre de son frère
en brandissant sa boîte à bout de bras
parce qu'elle a un peu peur quand même.
Elle sait bien qu'en réalité
c'est pas trop possible.
Je ne vous raconte pas la fin.
Pas tout de suite.
En tout cas ce que je peux déjà vous dire,
c'est que c'est important
une boîte à soleil.
C'est très important
d'avoir une boîte à soleil au fond de soi.
Je me souviens de Mathieu.
Celle-ci, c'est une histoire vraie.
Mathieu a 8 ans.
Je suis psy.
Je le reçois au cabinet en urgence.
Mathieu est assis en face de moi,
il est effondré.
Il sanglote sans pouvoir s'arrêter.
Il hoquette.
En fait, la veille au soir,
il regarde tranquillement la télé
avec son papa et sa maman.
Il leur fait un baiser de bonne nuit,
il part se coucher.
Et soudain le matin,
c'est le drame absolu.
Son papa, jeune, est mort brutalement
d'une rupture d'anévrisme.
Effroyable.
Et moi, en face de ce petit bonhomme
noyé dans ses larmes,
je suis complètement désemparée.
Mais qu'est-ce que je peux faire ?
Qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour l'aider ?
Mais à quoi ça me sert d'être psy ?
Bien sûr dans mon métier,
j'ai appris des tas de théories.
Ok, j'ai accumulé
des ribambelles de connaissances.
Bien sûr, j'ai été formée
à de multiples techniques
psychothérapeutiques.
Ok.
Ok, on m'a théoriquement appris
à soulager la souffrance.
Mais là, face à cet enfant
qui pleure si fort,
et c'est tellement normal
que cet enfant pleure
dans ces circonstances,
qu'est-ce que je peux faire ?
Qu'est-ce que je peux trouver ?
Tout ce que je sais ne me sert à rien.
Alors je me tais.
Je me centre.
Je prends une grande respiration.
Je ferme les yeux.
Enfin je crois,
je ne me souviens plus très bien.
Et surtout, je me relie
à ce que je ressens au plus profond de moi
pour essayer de trouver une idée,
quelque chose à lui dire.
Je plonge littéralement
dans mes ressources.
J'essaie en tout cas.
Je sais que je ne peux pas le consoler.
Il a 8 ans ! Son papa est mort !
Mais j'aimerais tellement l'apaiser,
même un tout petit peu.
Et puis je réouvre les yeux,
je plonge mon regard dans le sien
et je m'entends lui dire : « Tu sais,
au fond de toi, tu as un trésor.
Un immense trésor.
Et ce trésor, c'est tout l'amour
que tu as partagé avec ton papa.
C'est tous les moments
que vous avez passés ensemble.
C'est tous les baisers, tous les câlins
que vous avez eus tous les deux.
Et ce trésor, tu sais quoi ?
La mort ne l'a pas emporté.
Tu l'auras toujours au fond de toi.
Et tu pourras aller y puiser
tout au long de ta vie
et aussi dans les moments
les plus difficiles de ton existence
et même quand tu seras grand.
C'est ta boîte à soleil. »
Pendant quelques secondes,
Mathieu me regarde,
il retient sa respiration
comme s'il était en suspens.
Puis ses larmes reprennent,
et on se tait tous les deux.
J'ai revu Mathieu,
il n'y a pas très longtemps.
Un Mathieu presque adulte.
Et il m'a dit
qu'il se souvenait bien de ce jour-là,
car au milieu de ses larmes,
il avait ressenti quelque chose de chaud.
Et que ça l'avait profondément marqué.
Et qu'il s'en était toujours souvenu
et que ça l'avait beaucoup aidé.
C'est pour ça que c'est si important
d'avoir une boîte à soleil.
Et d'avoir cette intention de la remplir
à chaque instant de sa vie.
Tout le monde peut capturer du soleil.
Tout le monde peut apprendre à capturer
ces micro-moments de vie
qui sont doux, qui sont agréables,
qui nous fond chaud au cœur.
Mais auxquels il faut être très attentif
parce qu'ils sont tellement éphémères.
Souvent, on passe à côté,
on ne les voit pas.
On ne les saisit pas.
Et pour graver ces petits bonheurs,
il faut faire très attention,
parce qu'on passe beaucoup de notre temps,
beaucoup de notre vie à attendre.
À attendre quoi ?
Le Bonheur. Ou à courir après lui.
Ce Bonheur avec un grand B.
Ce Bonheur majuscule.
Vous savez, celui qui viendra après,
quand on aura plus d'argent,
quand on aura une maison,
quand on aura des enfants.
Ou quand les enfants seront grands.
Quand on sera en couple
ou quand on sera séparés, c'est selon.
Comme si un jour,
le Bonheur arrivait en nous disant :
« Hum, bonjour, je suis le Bonheur.
Je crois que vous m'attendez
depuis longtemps. »
Non, ça ne marche pas comme ça.
Ça ne marche pas comme ça le bonheur.
Ce sont les petits bonheurs.
Les petits b. Les b minuscules.
Les bonheurs ordinaires qui font,
qui fabriquent.
Le bonheur extra-ordinaire.
C'est comme ça, c'est tout.
Et pour graver en soi ces petits bonheurs,
la seule chose dont nous ayons besoin,
c'est de notre corps.
Et ça tombe bien
parce qu'il est tout le temps avec nous.
Le bonheur, ça s'attrape en ressentant.
En ressentant vraiment.
Le bonheur, ça se sent.
Hop. Je m'arrête un instant.
Je me relie à moi,
aux émotions qui sont là,
et je les ancre,
au plus profond de mon corps.
Je vis un moment agréable,
n'importe lequel.
Hop, je le sens, je le grave.
Je suis avec quelqu'un que j'aime :
hop, je le mets dans ma boîte.
Avec tout le bonheur que je ressens.
Ou encore... Enfin, ça c'est mon truc.
Vous savez les gouttes de pluie
sur les vitres,
quand les trains roulent,
surtout très vite.
Ça fait comme des feux d'artifices.
J'adore ça.
Je peux regarder pendant des heures.
Et hop ! Je capture ce moment
pour le mettre dans ma boîte.
Je mange quelque chose dont je raffole
- en ce moment, c'est les cerises -
plutôt que de les engloutir, je ralentis,
je prends mon temps et... Hop !
Tiens, et là si on faisait une expérience
tous ensemble ?
Vous êtes d'accord ?
Si on ramenait tous notre attention
sur nos sensations.
Celles qu'on peut sentir.
Juste là.
Peut-être la sensation de ma posture,
de mon corps assis, ou debout.
Peut-être que je peux juste un peu bouger
pour mieux le sentir.
Et puis, tranquillement,
et si j'en ai envie,
seulement si j'en ai envie,
je peux fermer les yeux.
Alors moi je vais fermer les yeux,
donc je vais vous perdre de vue.
Et maintenant, je vois
si je peux focaliser mon attention
sur les points de contact de mon corps.
Peut-être sur le haut de mes cuisses
ou de mes fesses sur le siège
ou peut-être le dos
appuyé contre le dossier
ou sur mes pieds,
la pression de mes pieds sur le sol.
Tout ce que je peux sentir.
Je ramène mon attention,
comme si je refermais
les volets de ma maison,
non pas pour être coupée du monde,
mais au contraire pour être mieux reliée
à moi-même et aux autres.
Qu'est-ce que je peux sentir ?
Qu'est-ce que je peux sentir
dans mon corps ?
Est-ce que je peux sentir
que je suis là ?
Vraiment là.
Souvent on le sait qu'on est là,
mais dans notre tête on est ailleurs.
Souvent très loin. Pas vraiment là.
Et là, juste là, juste maintenant.
Est-ce que je peux me relier,
entrer en contact avec mes sensations ?
Mes sensations sont agréables ?
Je le sens. Je le sens vraiment ?
Hop, je peux les mettre
dans ma boîte à soleil. Ou pas.
C'est comme ça une boîte à soleil.
Être attentif, vraiment présent,
avec tout son corps,
avec tous ses sens, à ce qu'on vit.
Et puis, pour ceux qui les ont fermés,
je peux doucement réouvrir les yeux.
Et qu'est-ce qu'il se passe
dans notre cerveau quand on fait ça ?
Quand on est totalement relié
à ce qu'on est en train de vivre.
Et ça, ce sont les neurosciences
qui le disent.
Notre cerveau déclenche la sécrétion
de tout un cocktail d'hormones
qui nous font du bien, nous apaisent :
les ocytocines, les endorphines...
Et du coup, ce moment vécu
va venir enrichir notre boîte à soleil,
notre trésor.
Parce que bien sûr, la boîte à soleil
n'empêche pas les malheurs de l'existence.
Elle ne peut pas permettre
d'éviter les souffrances.
Mais elle permet de les amortir.
Elle permet d'avoir des ressources
pour aller y puiser.
Pour ne pas être vidé au sens propre.
Pour ne pas se faire engloutir.
Et si c'était ça le chemin
pour vivre mieux ?
Et si c'était vraiment celle-là,
la psychologie d'aujourd'hui ?
C'est une vraie bascule.
On passe de l'archéologie de la souffrance
à la psychologie des ressources.
Une psychologie
qu'on pourrait appeler préventive.
Celle qui nous donne des clés
pour nos vies.
Celle qui finalement nous apprend
comment nourrir
et cultiver les champs fertiles,
plutôt que de s'épuiser à tenter
d'arracher les mauvaises herbes.
Parce que ce qui est hallucinant,
c'est qu'on continue à fonctionner
comme à la préhistoire.
Notre cerveau
est resté génétiquement programmé
comme les hommes des cavernes.
Notre amygdale,
cette petit zone qui est nichée
au fin fond de notre cerveau archaïque
et dont la fonction
est de décoder les émotions,
se déclenche tout le temps
face à ce qui est perçu comme une menace,
comme un danger,
comme si notre survie en dépendait.
Et alors des milliers d'années après,
on continue de vivre
en état d'alerte permanent.
On est polarisé sur ce qui ne va pas,
c'est ce qu'on voit en premier,
qu'on voit en grand.
C'est ce qui attire immédiatement
notre attention.
C'est pour ça
qu'il est tellement important, urgent,
d'apprendre à modifier le câblage,
la programmation.
C'est pour ça qu'il faut s'entraîner.
Et la bonne nouvelle, c'est que
notre cerveau est plastique, malléable,
ça s'appelle la neuroplasticité.
Et grâce à la capture des petits b,
on va restructurer notre cerveau,
on va créer de nouvelles connexions,
on va tracer de nouveaux chemins.
Et c'est ça qui change tout.
Entraîner notre cerveau
à se focaliser automatiquement
sur ce qui va bien.
Et comme ça, on remplit
notre boîte à soleil,
presque sans y penser.
Ah oui, vous vous souvenez ?
Vous vous souvenez,
dans l'histoire de la petite fille,
que le soir venu
la boîte à soleil brillait ?
Et vous savez pourquoi ?
Elle avait attrapé un ver luisant.
Génial, non ?
Déjà elle avait pris un plaisir fou
à courir toute la journée avec sa boîte
et en plus, elle a vraiment attrapé
un bout de soleil.
Quelquefois, dans la vie aussi,
c'est comme ça.
On croit que ce n'est pas possible.
Et pourtant.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)